[Musik]
willkommen zu unserem kurzen nachrichten
überblick wer mit astrazeneca erst
geimpft wurde der sollte als zweites
biontech oder moderner bekommen diese
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
wollen die bundesländer jetzt schnell
umsetzen
das erhöhe den schutz gegen korona
britta spiekermann impfen auf dem
wochenmarkt bramsche niedersachsen die
meisten stehen schlange für die zeit hin
ich habe die erste impfung kinder mir
und freue mich jetzt weiß ich endlich
die zweite auch habe und nicht mit der
auswahl mit bayern chef
er folgt damit der gestrigen empfehlung
der ständigen impfkommission nicht
überall dürfte der im stoffwechsel so
unkompliziert sein minister sparen wirbt
jetzt für die kombilösung das im
intervall könne sogar auf vier wochen
verkürzt werden dieses im schema diese
kombination von astra zenica und amerika
im stoff ist besonders wirksam der auch
die zweite impfung mit astrazeneca
geplant hat könnte also den impfstoff
wechseln 500 bis 700 tausend menschen
sind allein in der kommenden woche
betroffen engpässe in praxen und im
zentrum soll es nicht geben
es wird doch jetzt sehr zügig gehen
können diese empfehlung auch umzusetzen
weil ausreichend mm stoff da es für
bereits mit astra durch geimpfte könnte
allerdings eine dritte impfung notwendig
werden viel verunsicherung bei steigende
liefermengen noch in diesem jahr sind
weitere 30 millionen us weniger
impfdosen für deutschland eingeplant der
impfstoff hat aber das potenzial zum
ladenhüter
es ist der abschiedsbesuch von kanzlerin
merkel in großbritannien und zugleich
ein neubeginn mit promi johnson nach dem
wechsel beide vereinbarten regelmäßige
regierungsgespräche merkel stellte zudem
in aussicht die strikten
einreisebeschränkungen für vollständig
geimpfte briten zu lockern
im anschluss empfängt die queen die
kanzlerin auf schloss windsor
nach fast 20 jahren ist der
internationale truppenabzug in
afghanistan so gut wie abgeschlossen
nato und us einheiten haben den
hauptstützpunkt imba gramm geräumt auf
der militärbasis nördlich der hauptstadt
kabul waren zeitweise zehntausende
daten stationiert jetzt wurde das
gelände afghanischen sicherheitskräften
übergeben
die bundeswehr hatte ihren einsatz am
mittwoch beendet eine woche nach der
tödlichen messerattacke in würzburg hat
die stadt der opfer gedacht unter dem
motto würzburg trauerte würzburg hält
zusammen bildeten hunderte teilnehmer in
der innenstadt eine menschenkette
vergangenen freitag hatte ein somalia
drei frauen getötet und sieben menschen
zum teil schwer verletzt
er war zuvor psychisch auffällig gewesen
ein mögliches islamistisches motiv wird
geprüft
das zdf bekommt einen neuen intendanten
der fernsehrat den bisherigen programm
direktor norbert himmler gewählt er
tritt das amt im nächsten jahr an als
nachfolger von thomas bellut
nach seiner wahl äußerte sich himmer zu
seinem ziel das zdf hat einen
gesellschaftlichen auftrag und er wird
immer wichtiger
wir müssen alle menschen erreichen mit
tiefgründiger information mit aufklärung
aber auch mit guter unterhaltung wir
wollen alle menschen in deutschland
erreichen deshalb ist es mein ziel dass
jeder und jede sagen kann für mich ist
beim zdf auch etwas dabei und noch eine
personalie vom fußball toni kroos
beendet seine karriere in der
nationalmannschaft nach 106 spielen
der 31 jährige will sich jetzt voll auf
real madrid konzentrieren
fehlt noch das wetter östlich der elbe
gibt es einige schauer sonst ist es
freundlich westlich des rheins sind
einzelne gewitter möglich die
höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 21 und
27 grad
ich wünsche ihnen jetzt noch einen
spannenden fußballabend und sagt tschüss